l'oeil humain c'est la lentille de notre
monde coloré
quand la lumière est suffisante les
formes et les mouvements sont captés par
la rétine et transmis au cerveau
mais dans l'obscurité les couleurs
disparaissent nous voyons l'univers en
noir et blanc
il nous manque le spectacle de la
lumière
pourtant les étoiles ne sont pas
dépourvus de couleur c'est notre oeil
qui n'est pas capable de les voir à une
telle distance
ils ne peuvent pas capté assez de
lumière les couleurs du cosmos sont
invisibles à l'oeil humain
et nous sommes distraits par nos propres
lumières avions satellites magasin rue
le premier à voir les étoiles à travers
un télescope
füle italien galilée mais il ne vit
aucune couleur sa lunette astronomique
ne captait pas plus de lumière qu'une
paire de jumelles moderne
pourtant galilée nous a ouvert les
portes de la galaxie il a découvert des
lunes autour de jupiter
il a vu des cratères sur notre lune il a
annoncé que les planètes tournait autour
du soleil
non
et quand il a levé les yeux vers la voie
lactée il n'a pas vu seulement une bande
lumineuse un peu flou mais des millions
et des millions des toiles
deux siècles et demi plus tard en orbite
autour de la terre
le télescope spatial à bâle et le tube
optique d'aujourd'hui
le télescope hubble n'a pas découvert la
couleur mais il a vu des détails
invisibles auparavant
dans une clarté éblouissante le cosmos
livre ses secrets
l'oeil humain et comme une caméra
l'objectif est devant la pupille ajuste
son ouverture
selon la quantité de lumière le point se
fait sur la rétine au fond de l'oeil et
l'image est transmise au cerveau
pourtant même ouverte au maximum nos
pupilles sont trop étroites pour voir le
ciel nocturne en couleurs elle collecte
trop peu de lumière pour déclencher nos
récepteurs de couleurs il nous faut une
lunette
c'est un réfractaire la lumière est
simplement collectés à travers une
grande lentilles et agrandi grâce à un
éclair
c'est le plus ancien type de lunettes le
même modèle que celui utilisé par
galilée
l'inconvénient durée facteur vient de la
taille de leurs lentilles si elle mesure
plus de 90 cm de diamètre elle se
déforme sous son propre poids
les grands télescopes modernes sont des
réflecteurs la lumière est réfléchie par
un miroir
le miroir de ce réflecteurs mesure près
de quatre mètres 20 de diamètre
le scientifique anglais isaac newton fut
le premier à se servir d'un réflecteur
et aaron démontrer l'efficacité un
réflecteur à deux miroirs ou plus
legrand est comme un saut qui se rempli
de lumière un miroir peut être beaucoup
plus grand qu'une lentille car il est
plus facile à adapter sur la monture de
l'instrument en pénétrant dans le
réflecteur la lumière rebondi d'abord
sur le grand miroir puis sur un miroir
plus petits jusqu'aux foyers où elle rpi
est enregistrée électroniquement
plutôt que de regarder en clignant des
yeux à travers des télescopes les
astronomes d'aujourd'hui analyse par
ordinateur les images est rarement
quelques photos d'où provient ce
fantastique spectacle de lumière que les
astronomes observent la lumière
régénérer quand les électrons d'un atome
passe d'un niveau d'énergie à un autre
il dit ravi de l'énergie cette énergie
et la lumière
les étoiles sont si éloignées que leur
lumière mais des centaines des milliers
et même des millions d'années pour nous
atteindre
et elle ne nous envoie pas seulement de
la lumière visible elles émettent tout
un spectre de radiation la lumière
visible et au centre les rayons gamma à
gauche aux longueurs d'onde les plus
courtes les ondes radio à droite aux
longueurs d'onde les plus longues
cette image radio montre les débris
d'une étoile qui a explosé
une autre image radio des nuages de gaz
s'échappant d'une galaxie en détresse
en utilisant des antennes paraboliques
au lieu de miroirs les radiotélescopes
fonctionnent comme des réflecteurs
optique les ondes radios sont captés et
renvoyé vers un foyer au dessus de
chaque antenne
les antennes paraboliques sont grandes
parce que les longueurs d'onde qu'elles
captent sont beaucoup plus grande que
celle de la lumière visible les antennes
fonctionne de jour comme de nuit quelles
que soient les conditions météo
le radiotélescope parks en australie est
célèbre pour son travail sur les pulsars
les pulsars sont de minuscules étoiles
très dense
mesurant seulement une quinzaine de
kilomètres de diamètre mais dont la
masse est égale à celle de notre soleil
pour être mesuré leurs pulsations
doivent être débarrassés du bruit de
fond cosmique mais aussi des bruits
terrestres tels que ceux provenant des
fours à micro ondes et des démarreurs de
voiture
non
ce n'est qu'alors que la pulsation du
pulsar peut se faire entendre
le bac mandat pulsar effectué plusieurs
révolutions par seconde
ici les astronomes observent
simultanément deux plus tard
ce sont des reliques de gigantesque
étoile qui ont explosé en supernova
décor stellaire mort condamné à émettre
des bips radio pour l'éternité
d'autres images radio nous regardons de
la matière se précipitaient autour d'un
trou noir
et cela recommence
lorsque les radiotélescopes s'associent
pour observer le ciel à l'unisson les
images sont d'autant plus riches en
détails
c'est ce qu'il se passe au nouveau
mexique levet est là le very large array
comprend 27 antenne montés sur des rails
et disposés en forme de y
couvrant plus de 1200 kilomètres carrés
ils se tournent comme des tournesols
pour suivre la course des étoiles
ensemble ils fouillent le cosmos avec la
puissance d'une antenne unique de 27 km
de diamètre
et quand ils sont reliés à cette antenne
à hawaï et à celle ci à porto rico
ils forment un télescope de plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres de diamètre
quand ils sont tous connectés à travers
le monde ils forment une antenne de la
taille de la terre un télescope si
puissant qu'il peut observer des objets
qui brillait avant que la vie n'apparaît
sur terre
les télescopes de plusieurs nations sont
regroupées sur un sommet volcanique à
hawaï à environ 4200 mètres d'altitude
ils sont à mi hauteur de l'atmosphère
ici le ciel est dégagé sans nuage il a
peur d'aucune absorbe le rayonnement
infrarouge et recueillie
l'infrarouge révèle la chaleur il
traverse les poussières et nous permet
de voir à travers les nuages sombres
naissent les étoiles
nimbé de poussière voici une partie de
notre galaxie en lumière visible la même
région dans l'infrarouge
il
l'infrarouge et si proche de la lumière
visible que les deux types d'image se
ressemblent cependant il nous ouvre les
portes du coeur même de la voie lactée
un visible au télescope optique
nous
venus est toujours enveloppé de nuages
lavera rouge révèle des détails de sa
surface
bon
les rayons infrarouges sur découvert en
angleterre par un astronome william
herschel horschel doit sa gloire à sa
découverte de la planète uranus mais
aussi à ses télescopes
le plus grand mesure et un mètre vingt
de diamètre malgré cette taille il ne
vit d'uranus qu'un point
uranus resta inaccessible jusqu'à ces
photos prises en 1994 par le télescope
spatial à bâle
elle montre des formations de nuages
et pour la première fois avec un
télescope optique à bas le capturera les
anneaux d'uranus
arch elle pensait avoir vu des trous
dans le ciel il se trompait ce sont des
globules sombre des nuages de poussière
noirs qui flottent devant ces étoiles
pourtant leur seul était un remarquable
observateurs il a dessiné une carte des
étoiles avec le soleil au centre
en irlande des télescopes de plus en
plus gros fut reconstruit
en 1845 le troisième compte de ross
construisit ce monstre muni d'un miroir
d'un mètre quatre-vingt dans le parc de
son château pendant 75 ans se
télescopent fut le plus grand au monde
nuit après nuit le comte suivait des
objets dans le ciel il les regarder à
travers le télescope puis reproduisent
et leurs positions sur une feuille de
papier la même région sur une
photographie moderne
son dessin de la nébuleuse du crabe la
photo moderne
ross a donné son nom à la nébuleuse du
crabe
ce sont les restes d'une étoile géante
qui a explosé il ya neuf cent cinquante
ans dans cette superbe image
le télescope hubble identifie le pulsar
qui reste en son centre
l'irlande nuageuse n'est pas le meilleur
endroit pour observer les étoiles
pourtant ross a persévéré son télescope
fut surnommé le monstre de par sunshine
voici ses dessins de ce qu'on appelait
alors une nébuleuse spirale
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est une
galaxie la galaxie du chien de chasse
qui est en interaction avec une galaxies
plus petites
depuis des centaines de millions
d'années
ici lors d'une simulation par ordinateur
des étoiles et des traînées de gaz dans
l'espace
elles ont l'air proche et pourtant les
galaxies sont séparés par une distance
de dix à quinze mille années lumière
des milliards d'étoilés jouant au chat
et à la souris
bubble à regarder au plus profond de la
galaxie du chêne chasse une partie de la
tâche sombre au centre pourrait être un
grand anneau de poussière en rotation
autour d'un trou noir
au début du 20e siècle
les télescopes et est devenue
gigantesque celui ci le télescope de
hooker fut terminée en 1917 afin de
profiter d'un ciel noir et d'un air
limpide il fut installé sur le mont
wilson près de pasadena en californie
les astronomes n'avait pas prévu
l'expansion de los angeles
le télescope du mont wilson était le
premier instrument vraiment moderne
son miroir mesure deux mètres cinquante
de diamètre
afin de le maintenir en position des
moteurs électriques des places se
télescopent et les permettent de
compenser le mouvement de la terre
malgré sa taille gigantesque
il bouge tout en douceur
les éligibles inconfortable de herschel
et de ross appartiennent au passé
l'astronome georges elle qui a imaginé
ce télescope a placé l'observateur au
sein même de l'instrument
du sommet de cette montagne des
découvertes fondamentales furent faites
et l'astronomie moderne est devenu
adulte
le réflecteur de deux mètres cinquante
au sommet du mont wilson nous a révélé
notre position dans l'espace
nous ne sommes pas au centre du monde le
soleil est situé à la périphérie extrême
d'un gigantesque disque des toiles une
spirale plus enflé en son centre une
galaxie que nous avons baptisé la voie
lactée
mais y at il autre chose que notre
galaxie dans l'univers les observateurs
du mont wilson répondirent par
l'affirmative et un astronome découvrit
pourquoi se fit edwin à bâle qui donna
son nom au télescope spatial en 1923 à
bâle pris une série de mesures d'une
importance capitale à travers le
télescope du wilson
il observait des étoiles variables dites
céphéides dans cette région du ciel des
étoiles dont l'éclat changent avec le
temps elles sont l'une des clef pour
calculer les distances
elles sont si éloignées que hubble a
réalisé qu'il regardait une autre
galaxie à plus de deux millions d'années
lumière de la nôtre la balle venait
d'identifier andromède l'une des
galaxies les plus proches de la nôtre et
ils en découvrent y de nombreux autres
il pensait que la forme des galaxies
indiqué leur évolution
elle commençait sous forme d'agrégats en
forme qui se condense est de plus en
plus elle développé des bras qui
pensait-il grandissait et s'enrouler
autour de la grée xi comme une pelote de
laine
on
apple avait tort les galaxies peuvent
avoir des formes différentes quel que
soit leur âge
pourtant sa conception générale du
cosmos était juste à bol montra que
partout des galaxies s'éloignent les
unes des autres
il avait découvert l'expansion de
l'univers et ouvert la voie à l'idée que
tout débuta par un big bang
en 1948 et louis nobel devint le
directeur du plus grand télescope au
monde
le réflecteur de à elle de 5 m de
diamètre au sommet du mont palomar en
californie
mais le bol était en fin de carrière
plus tard on lui attribue à la
contribution la plus importante à la
cosmologie depuis l'époque de copernic
quatre siècles plus tôt copernic avait
émis l'idée que les planètes tournait
autour du soleil
tandis qu'à bâle céder la place des
astronomes plus jeunes une grande
quantité de télescopes furent mises en
chantier dans le monde entier en route
vers les étoiles
en amérique la plus grande collection de
télescopes fut réunie à qui tu piques en
arizona
c'est un lieu d'observation idéal pour
les astronomes assez haut pour ne pas
subir la distorsion de l'atmosphère
basse assez éloignée pour éviter la
pollution de l'air et de la lumière
assez sec pour pouvoir observer le ciel
presque chaque soir
il n'y a pas de meilleur endroit pour
assister au spectacle des lumières du
cosmos
sauf peut-être dans les andes à la cia
au chili où se trouve le télescope
européen austral
au large de l'afrique sur un sommet
volcaniques dans les îles canaries
le télescope anglais william herschel
fait partie d'un autre groupe de
télescopes
et au dessus des nuages sur le mauna kea
à hawaï se dresse le dernier et le plus
moderne les dom des télescopes de cac
des jumelles cosmique
cake ressemble à une cathédrale double
non
c'est le plus grand télescope au monde
deux miroirs chacun le double de la
largeur du réflecteur géant de palomar
reliée électroniquement mesurant près de
10 mètres de diamètre est construit
comme un puzzle
ils sont formés de trente deux segments
de verre hexagonaux
chaque segment est contrôlé par
ordinateur il ne faut qu'une fraction de
seconde pour les déplacés ainsi ils
compensent la distorsion sur l'image
causés par l'atmosphère ou par le plus
petit changement de position du
télescope
cake est encore en période d'essai et
pourtant il fournit déjà des
informations
comme cette magnifique image de la
nébuleuse eskimos
et cette galaxie en spirale
le télescope spatial à bâle et des
astronautes au travail
libéré de l'atmosphère terrestre à bâle
devait être l'oeil le plus perçant
jamais braqués sur les étoiles dans
toute l'histoire de l'astronomie mais il
eu un problème le miroir principal
légèrement déformé fournit des premières
images floues la solution fut de
corriger à bâle de sa myopie
la navette spatiale fut envoyé vers
hubble
sa mission réparer le miroir défectueux
en lui ajoutant des lentilles en guise
de lunettes
simple sur terre délicat dans l'espace
et ils ont réussi à bâle pu reprendre sa
route et ses observation de la terre
les astronomes pur tester les nouvelles
lentilles elle fonctionnait
depuis 1994 les images prises par hubble
nous ont réjoui émerveillé et étonné les
astronomes ont dû reconsidérer la
justesse d'anciennes théorie et même de
l'âge de l'univers dans notre quête des
étoiles la lunette de galilée fut une
invention merveilleuse baballe va peut
être s'avérer encore plus importante